ce que nous disent les scientifiques le
conseil scientifique et c 'est qu' il
faudrait qu'on redescende aux alentours
de 1500 patients kovy denrées à
pour qu'on considère que le
fonctionnement normal les hôpitaux
seraient restaurés ce qui à ce rythme
pourrait intervenir d'ici deux à trois
semaines puisqu'on est en diminution de
la charge sanitaire en réanimation au
travers de sept ministres henri tco vite
c'est vraiment les patients koffi les
lampes alors bien sûr alors il est
patient pourrait avec kobe que vous avez
raison de souligner il ya un écart qui
peut être conséquent s'agissant des
patients hospitalisés en soi qu'on en
soins conventionnels en soins critiques
l'écart est beaucoup plus restreint et
il a tendance à se réduire évidemment
puisque - le virus circule moins vous
avez de risque de tomber aléatoirement
sur un patient qui est là pour tout
autre chose et qui est un dico vide le
deuxième indicateur rapidement c'est la
dynamique épidémique est là le constat
les scientifiques nous il faut que
facteur aire de reproduction du virus
soit durablement inférieure à 1 c'est là
qu'on soit sur une pente décroissante et
que on a atteint un niveau de taux
d'incidence qu'ils soient assez faibles
entre 300 500 au plus fort au maximum
pour pouvoir considérer qu' on a
vraiment franchi le plus dur aux on va
l'atteindre et là aussi je pense qu'on
atteindra d'ici deux à trois semaines
maxi ce qui te bonne nouvelle on voit
qu'elle a de la décrue de l'épidémie on
voit là les sorties d'hospitalisation
néanmoins il ya eu pas loin de ne pas
dire de bêtises mais il ya eu encore pas
beaucoup de décès hier qu'ont été
enregistrés donc c'était 290 effet ce
qui est pardonnez moi de le dire
beaucoup c'est 10 % de la mortalité
routière annuel
les gens ont le sentiment que quand on
écoute parler de la pandémie en ce
moment c'est pareil en france et dans le
reste du monde en tout cas en europe
mais homologues européens me disait le
décompte de quotidiens des décès
une donnée qui ne paraît plus centrale
dans l'esprit d'un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens alors qu'en réalité le virus
s'est aussi l'impact principal en
réalité que de faire perdre la vie aux
gens qui sont dans des attaques graves à
la base et qui meurt quand j'entends sur
des plateaux de télé des gens dire on a
bien vu qu'au micro ne donnait pas de
cas graves basque usées mois mais une
maladie qui fait 250 morts ou 280 morts
sur une journée dans notre pays y en a
pas beaucoup
il n'a pas beaucoup
donc le comité continue dans et déclare
par contre on a un effet de protection
populationnelle grâce à la vaccination
donc je vous ai dit charge sanitaire
hospitalière capacité des hôpitaux à
fonctionner le plus normalement possible
une très forte réduction du taux
d'incidence est une dynamique épidémique
qui restent baissières sont les critères
dont nous tenons et tiendront compte
[Musique]
vous